this is something fans of winter sports
won't be seeing again anytime soon
this year the swiss resort of davos
clusters celebrated 150 years of winter
sports with a nostalgic bobsled and
toboggan race
the first ever time toboggan race was
held right here in 1883.
the race featured dozens of vintage
toboggan sleds dating from 1890 the
1930s and the 1960s
a few other rather unusual creations
also went to the starting line
the participants included amateur
tobogganers and champion bobsledders
like eckahart fossur olympic gold
medalist european and world champion and
world cup winner
back then he raced through winding ice
tunnels
conditions today aren't quite the same
it's so warm right now that this isn't
ice
it's just packed snow
and these bobsleds aren't really suited
for racing on snow
that's no obstacle for the former pro
athlete
but less experienced participants have
to resort to creative tactics
this is how it looked one day earlier
it's a road
race organizer klaus holler and his
colleagues from the international
tobogganing club in davos had to
recreate the old bobsled and toboggan
run in weather that was plus two degrees
celsius
building the curve especially with the
warm temperatures we're having right now
was a real challenge
first we had to prepare all the blocks
of ice and after that we built
everything
tomorrow we'll have to cover the entire
road with snow which will be a lot of
work
800 cubic meters of snow and a year of
preparation 150 years of winter sports
has lots of history behind it
friedrich
and hugo richter from germany were the
first two winter tourists in davos
clusters back in 1865.
in 1879 tobogganing joined the modern
era legend has it that two englishmen
held the first timed race here
local residents turned that into
bobsledding
in 1872 the first curling event took
place
and in 1890 the first ever ski tour was
organized here
that was soon followed by ice hockey
the resort has another highlight for
visitors this natural skating rink
opened in 1880
the largest drink of its kind in europe
it's popular with amateur skaters
and the pros
the long tradition of winter sports is
immortalized in the davos museum which
has many old artifacts in its collection
including toboggans
bobsleds
and vintage skis
it's winter sports that made the small
resort in switzerland famous
though davos has just 15 000 residents
today it's among the world's top winter
destinations
about 360 000 tourists come here each
year
more than twice as many as 50 years ago
i'm from alicante in spain i'm here for
the weekend to ski conditions are very
good and we're enjoying ourselves here
i came from belarus and this is my
second time in davos i'm from moscow
russia and i like davos a lot and i
think it's the best resort in
switzerland
the nostalgic toboggan and bobsled race
has also drawn an international audience
here to enjoy the event that had its
start with winter tourists from britain
it just sort of feels part of the
heritage of the swiss swiss winter
sports and swiss winter tourism which
the english
have done we've been so involved over so
many years
as long as the snow holds out davos
hopes to remain a popular destination
for fans of winter sports